who wants to help defense it go ahead
yep okay let me help you out - puppy and
then see if you can take over for Part C
okay excuse me I gave you this Twitter
right this guy over here this helps you
work out what happens when X is really
large when you get far far away on this
side you could do the same exercise for
X approaching negative bidding gets
rescue e you get pretty much exactly the
same result so what that tells me is add
very very far x values this theme is the
winner right yeah why is this that's the
one it's just another letter for y so
therefore I have a horizontal asymptote
of y equals 1 do you see that Y this
thing equals 1 that's why I'm
approaching an enormous positive and
enormous negative okay there's one of
the asymptotes what's the other one
now be specific right it's a kind of
acetone worker it's not this kind of
thing so what is it it's a vertical
asymptote which means it has an equation
of not two but x equals two and that's
important because the two could be
anything right so you've got to specify
so make sure you sign right let's pop x
equals two on there by the way equations
of your asymptotes important we see
after this report one of the other
feature we set first what do we say was
important the eggs are weighted that's
right if they are both so to find the
x-intercepts reasons what am I going to
do to this I'm going to let y equal 0 do
you notice when you go ahead and do that
when you let y equal 0
she just insisted Nevada becomes
unimportant do you realize that because
it doesn't matter what you make your
denominator so long as the numerator 0
you're good to go
right because 0 divided by anything
except 0 will give you the money that
you're after
ok so that means that my x-intercept is
going to be 1 this game feels do I have
a y-intercept as well what do I do to
get y instead you let X equal 0 the
opposite of this so you're going to get
1 over negative 2 so that's going to be
negative 1/2
okay this is all the information that I
need
I suppose I'm going to add one more
thing remember we said this limit as X
approaches infinity as X goes far over
there it's going to be 1 ok but it's
actually one from a particular direction
I actually gave you some numbers for
perform like this that's getting close
to infinity what is one more right a bit
that's getting even closer to kids and
don't you go but can you tell me by the
D numbers on it because it what are they
smaller than 113 speakers how could you
tell that there'll be we are going to a
calculator of gaining decimal out of it
how could you tell that the numerator is
ever so slightly bigger than the
denominator right and we used to learn a
number like that bigger than one and
number like this it's more than one yes
so therefore we're on approaching one
I'm actually approaching it from above 1
so therefore over a positive infinity
you're going to come down to one from
above this line this is the shape you're
going to get like that just like the
hyperbolas you've seen before this is
another kind of Pythagoras on the
left-hand side if I repeat the exercise
but with maybe values because negative
values instead of positive another
pretty negative pattern I'm going to
have negative 1 on the top 999 right
what's going to be on the bottom
I'm putting in negative a thousand
substituting in negative thousands
ticket of the classroom maybe it hasn't
to those thingies are going to cancel
Christmas children that is this number
above or below one isn't it ever so
slightly below one okay so just when I
approached here from the top I'm going
to approach here from the bottom which
is kind of what you expected again for a
regular type evolution there you go okay
so I'm going towards my asymptote I have
T that's why they're asymptotes I've got
the intercepts you told me about four
and this is enough isn't the graph okay
question so why don't we see what's
happening to stop
it's got two errors but I want to make
sure I'm coming from from this direction
not from that direction at the moment
you'd be hard-pressed to imagine what
what do you mean how can you come from
this direction if you're looking City
two intercepts down here one can later
on I'll give you more complicated
attention we'll do exactly that so just
confirming where I'm approaching this
assets I promise that exam it is I the
wine was one yes okay so I've got
vertical asymptotes and we know where
they come from they come from the
denominator right they come from values
that make the function break down
whether it's a domain restriction right
so a vertical asymptotes means you can't
you can't go there this is like out of
bounds the function cut exists there
yeah but horizontal hasn't nodes are
kind of different horizontal asymptotes
are about what's happening book really
large values events over here and what's
happening for really large values of
negative x over there so therefore what
I tried to work out was if I try some of
the time if I try really large Monday
night events or really large negative
values of x what is y this thing this is
why what's it going to approach and the
injuries as you crunch the numbers these
are all approaching one so later on
we're going to help with its analytical
way to do that rather than you
calculator what you're doing that
because you should be able to get to the
point like I have when you look at this
and you don't need to do this you can
say obvious from that one but we're not
quite sure okay so don't worry if it's a
little bit challenging its kind of
haven't introduced this ideas formally
yet I'm just trying to use that informal
source can I let you have a few moments
to have a go apart see with the same
kinds of tools that we did to part they
put all those speeches that I hope you
find from Part B I want you to look at
the [ __ ] and tell me what are they
and where do they come from there are
four that I can see so on anyone any
feature you pick tell me what it is and
why I know it's not many takers
okay if it tips the x-intercept is to
how they're done and then Wayne was you
won right and we might equal zero do
anything that makes that true is x
equals two
again remember it's about the numerator
there you don't can't with the generator
equals zero divided by 3 skill zero that
would be a cleaner Tommy something
awesome the y-intercept here it is at
negative two how did you find that your
let X equal zero it becomes quite easy
to evaluate P because I'm giving you
nice easy numbers so about these two are
this guy well just guy come from this
vertical asymptote again it comes to the
denominator just like I got x equals two
as a vertical asymptote here I'm going
to get x equals negative one and a
vertical asymptote here the last piece
of information is this guy which
interestingly is shared with this one
right where do I get that book I've got
it working on the board how do I know
the answer you can repeat this process
I'll give you a specific example here's
working one do you notice that pub in
Part C are reciprocals of each other
right so what's your reciprocal of one
also one right so that's why you end up
approaching gap width is 15 when you've
got the reciprocal okay now I just need
to join up the dots so if you have a
look you can see I've got to get this
shape over here and then you get this
opposite branch in the second quarter
okay are you happy so these functions
here are actually just sort of my stage
the real question I'm interested in in
that side now well in that manage sided
not just in general whether it means
something the points what design mean
what is reversing into that is a
positives and negatives right we may
want to put that under newly
you're heading to so to investigate the
idea of sign using these closures what I
want you to think about is what if I
could use these graphs to solve to solve
a set of three inequalities that are
each related to these functions okay
the employee that once you solve on the
basis of these graphs are X plus 1 X
minus 2 when did that point is Sid side
question partners this guy here with
that X plus 1 or X minus 2 greater than
0 R exactly
and lastly X minus 2 X plus 1
what is that positive you've got three
graphs positive just means above the
x-axis right take a minute to be read
and compare those to the person next to
you what